well i can definitely tell you beth is
that the best thing we can do to protect
ourselves protect our country and ensure
that we have as normal a christmas as
possible is to get boosted now and
it's just amazing to to be here in this
uh vaccination center in london in in
westminster and see huge numbers of
people listening to that message coming
forward and the way the nhs is
responding is just inspiring the the gps
uh the volunteers all the the nurses and
doctors uh really really pulling out all
the stops and we will ramp it up over
the next few days because it is a huge
huge target that we've set ourselves but
the
risk is plainly there we can see omicron
spiking now in in london and some other
parts of the country
here in the capital it probably
represents about 40 percent of the cases
by tomorrow it'll be the majority of the
cases and it's increasing the whole time
and sadly yes omicron is producing
hospitalizations and uh sadly at least
one patient has now
been confirmed to have died uh with
omicron so uh i think the idea that this
is somehow a milder version of the virus
i think that's something we need to set
on one side and just recognize the sheer
pace at which it accelerates through the
population so the best thing we can all
do is get our boosters uh we're opening
up centers across the country we're
getting in the uh the army to help with
the logistics uh we're expanding uh in
every possible way and
what we need now is for
the the public to respond and to do that
do what is necessary get boosted now
the question
was can you rule out more restrictions
and it seems you can't because you
didn't
so you can't rule out what are you
before christmas
let me just say on that that throughout
the pandemic beth i've been a great
pains to stress to the public that we we
have to watch where it where the
pandemic is going we we take whatever
steps are necessary to protect public
health we need data coming on saturday
we think that
the
uh steps that we're taking so
plan b
combined with a huge
hugely ambitious acceleration of the of
the booster campaign bringing it forward
by a month so we offer a booster to
every adult by the by the end of the
year uh we think that's the right
approach and
i think the the most important thing
everybody can do is get boosted now just
finally on that on saturday you are
going to get new data it would be
december the 18th
you can't tell me now whether you might
have to introduce further restrictions
what i can tell you is that we think
that looking at the the balance of the
other risks looking at the epidemiology
looking at where we are with omicron
everything we know don't forget there
are still some important things we don't
know about omicron we think that this is
the best approach combination of a plan
b which is some uh some sensible steps
to slow the spread of the virus to buy
us some time to help to
reduce the uh the infections and of
course the the mortality rate and then
combine that with rapidly building up
our booster defenses and everybody
should remember that the reason we're
doing this is because it became clear on
friday
that two jabs were not enough do you
remember so that was the key moment when
we realized we had to accelerate the
booster campaign because three jabs does
two jabs plus a booster does lift your
level of protection right back up do you
regret not doing more earlier in the
autumn now on the booster program
because that's been some of the
criticism that this is all too little
too late also the vaccine websites
crashed this morning and you can't get
any home tests
your flow tests have run out so several
things that beth number one i think the
people of this country and the the nhs
the gps the staff the volunteers they
should be incredibly proud of the
vaccine runner this is the fastest uh
booster booster rollout anywhere in
europe i think it's almost double the
percentage of most other european
countries we've done in the in the uk uh
we're going incredibly fast yes
we now want
to to hit warp speed and we'll have to
attain a a pace and a
a number of daily booster doses that
will exceed anything that we've done
before but i've got no doubt at all that
we have the people we have the
enthusiasm we have the the fundamental
optimism about what we can do which
we've learned from the experience of the
last 18 months and i know that people
are going to rise to this
people to isol or take daily tests from
tomorrow if they come into contact with
someone from code but they can't get any
i mean they can thank you thank you beth
we they can get uh they can get those
tests we do we we do have a a ready
supply of tests
there aren't any left
we do have a ready supply of lateral
flow test if you can't get one online
for any reason then there are ample
supplies in the in the shops uh but what
i think if i may say so what that also
shows is that people are doing the
sensible thing
and and getting tests as well
just in terms of i have two more things
to ask you that i think are very
important um
in terms of the restrictions which you
say are very important that people
adhere to the new rules that you are
voting on tomorrow up to 75 percent of
your own and 75 of your own mps say they
won't support it yeah so that means you
can't even keep
basic public health messaging and votes
under your control in your the prime
minister you've got to rely on labour
that is a desperate state of affairs
it's not sustainable is it i think that
what everybody needs to to recognize is
is a couple of things that the that
omicron is a very serious risk to public
health and that it's spreading very fast
and i think there's no there's no room
for for complacency but we have the
vaccines our position remains
incomparably better than it was last
year and i hope that people will also
understand colleagues in
in westminster around the country will
also see that the measures we're putting
in place are balanced and proportionate
and it is because of the vaccine rollout
because of what we've done that we
actually have an economy and a society
a society that is more open than
virtually any other in europe and what
we will also do now is greatly intensify
accelerate that vaccine uh that booster
rollout and urgent response to get
points getting boosted that you need
the votes to get this
critical
measures passed i mean that's terrible
beth i will make my case to my friends
to to the public to everybody what
drives me in this is concern for for
public health and uh what i think is
absolutely obvious to
everybody who studies the the data is
that if we can get boosted now protect
ourselves now then we'll have a much
much better chance of having a protected
nhs going into next year we won't have
the nhs overwhelmed people won't have
cancellations of
of cancer appointments and other
vital vital clinical needs
so much next year because we've got
boosted now and
the other crucial point is of course
that we'll be protecting our society
protecting our livelihoods and allowing
ourselves to keep going forward in the
way that we have over the last few
months i've got a final question on
christmas parties yes
numerous parties have now been recorded
or reported about uh in number 10 during
the lockdown last year and now it
emerges that you hosted a christmas
party quiz with groups of people in
various rooms in number 10 when such
things were banned have you asked simon
case to investigate you
i can tell you once again that i
certainly broke no rules uh all that is
being looked into but if i may
respectfully say to you uh that i do
think that when you look at
and of course all that must be properly
gone into you'll be hearing from uh from
the cabinet secretary about it all but
frankly uh when i look at what we're
we're trying to do to do now the crucial
thing is that people uh
understand the the challenge that is
posed by omicron but also understand
that this is a challenge that
collectively we can meet we have the
resources we have the vaccines we have
the vaccinators we're recruiting more
we're getting more people to volunteer
we'll be opening up uh more services and
mobilizing and i hope snowballing at a
big big national campaign and that is
frankly what i think we all say it
appears that the public care that you
seem to have participated in a social
event in number 10 when everyone was
told not to and i just i i hear you beth
i think you would have seen all that
your staff members on zooms in groups
around the building so you're saying it
didn't happen i can tell you that i
certainly break their rules but the
whole thing will be uh looked into by
uh the
cabinet secretary and what i'm focused
on frankly is the vaccine uh rollout and
and
the campaign to forget everybody to
understand how vital it is to get
boosted so you've asked simon case to
look at the december 5th he's been an
event just to be clear he's looking at
all these things december the 15 event
that's the one is that the
the thing with the zoom yes yeah
okay but frankly i think what everybody
uh
and you know
we'll we'll report back on all that uh
though as i say uh
as soon as we as soon as we reasonably
can but the key thing is
that we have a national campaign
a national mission and we need to to get
it done uh we need to everybody to
understand the vital importance of
getting boosted now i think people are
and it's it's it's pretty humbling to
see the numbers of people coming forward
it's pretty amazing to see the spirit
with which the vaccinators are
responding